Game of Thrones season 9 will definitely happen
in near future
because not only did the showrunners leave
space for someone to make it,
but they also left quite a few big clues in
the finale
that are hinting at huge plot twists for some
of the biggest characters,
like Dany's resurrection, return of many characters,
wars for succession all over Westeros
and Jon Snow being the new King beyond the
Wall.
Beside that, very well written and executed
season 9 of Game of Thrones
is the only thing that can redeem Game of
Thrones at this point
because season 8 was so bad and disappointing
that it killed re-watchability of the show
for so many people.
But if there would be a season 9 and it would
actually be good and answer many unanswered
questions, then season 8 would be nothing
more than a bad season with great previous
seasons
and with a great final season.
I'm aware that HBO could not do anything,
but oblige with David and Dan's wish to make
only 8 seasons when they actually wanted 10
which was because David and Dan were the ones
who had the rights to the story's adaptation.
Now when they are done with it, HBO could
and should
and probably will in near future make a sequel
or as I call it season 9 to continue the story
and repair the damage that's been done to
the Game of Thrones.
Thankfully, David and Dan left so much space
for it,
not having given answers to almost anything
in season 8,
not wrapping up so many stories and leaving
so many clues for what we can expect to happen
with most of our favorite characters as well
as leaving clues to what might happen all
over Westeros as well.
Let's take a look at what we can expect to
happen in the future sequel or season 9,
from Dany's hinted and almost confirmed resurrection
to wars across Westeros,
to all the characters we expected to see in
the season 8
and play a vital role will actually appear
and play their vital role in season 9,
to White Walker story back in the game, Jon
having yet to fulfill his purpose and the
Dragon Queen's revenge.
Where is Drogon taking killed Dany, was the
question which was answered at the end of
the finale, and I made a whole video explaining
it right after the show ended which was a
huge hit,
I mean the video, not the ending obviously.
In that video, I also explained why Drogon
is taking her to that place and what it means.
In the disappointing season 8 finale, Jon
founds himself with no choice, but to kill
Dany the Mad Queen, influenced by the destruction
of Kings Landing, but also by Tyrion Lannister
who convinced him that his family will never
be safe as long as Dany lives.
Anyways, Drogon, having a connection with
his mother,
came to the scene and it was a heart-breaking
moment.
Drogon nudges her, tries to wake her, and
it breaks my heart.
Having destroyed the one thing that made his
mother Daenerys mad and evil,
Drogon gently lifted his mother with his claws
and flew away across the Narrow Sea.
One question remained: Where exactly did Drogon
take Dany?
Sam answered that question in the small council
towards the end of the episode.
When King Bran asks for an update on the dragon’s
whereabouts late in the finale,
Sam says “He was last spotted flying east
toward Volantis–” before Bronn cuts him
off.
What this means is that Dany’s fate is left
up to a debate.
She’s dead and she might stay that way,
but she might also be resurrected by the Red
Priestess Kinvara who happens to be at the
same city Drogon was last spotted flying towards.
In fact, I think the showrunners wanted to
imply to us viewers that Dany will probably
not stay dead for long.
Why else would they mention Drogon flying
toward Volantis?
They could have had Drogon flying toward Valyria,
where Targaryens originate.
This could have been a possible destination
for them both,
seeing as it's where the Targaryens traditionally
lived with their dragons.
Second, they could have had Drogon flying
toward the Dothraki Sea.
Drogon and his dragon siblings were born in
Dothraki territory, and they could have had
him flying back to the place he feels is home.
But they didn’t.
They specifically mentioned Drogon flying
east towards Volantis.
So why Volantis and what’s in Volantis?
The first time we see Volantis is in season
5.
As Tyrion and Varys were making their way
through a market they spot a Red Priestess
preaching to a crowd of slaves, who catches
Tyrion's eye as he stops to listen to her
Sermon.
She preaches that the Lord of Light has sent
them a savior, the "Dragon Queen" – Daenerys
Targaryen, who has been WAGING a campaign
against slavery in Meereen.
It’s not just a city where people love and
support Dany, but more importantly, Volantis
is home to Kinvara, a red priestess who made
a brief appearance in season 6 to lend her
support to the Team Dany.
She met Tyrion Lannister and Varys in the
Great Pyramid of Meereen.
Tyrion asked her people to rally behind Daenerys,
to ask them to see her as their protector
and guardian, not a conqueror.
Kinvara was happy to assist Tyrion, saying
Daenerys
“is the one who was promised.
From the fire she was reborn to remake the
world...
Daenerys has been sent to lead the people
against the darkness in this war and in the
Great War still to come.”
Kinvara promised to spread the word about
Khaleesi throughout Essos.
So we know that the followers of the Lord
of Light stand behind Daenerys,
including Kinvara, who’s titles read: Flame
of Truth, Light of Wisdom, and the First Servant
of the Lord of Light, the High Priestess of
the Red Temple of Volantis.
She's one of the highest-ranking of R'hllor's
clerics.
Since she firmly believes that Daenerys Targaryen
is The Princess That Was Promised,
and the one who will make this world a better
place, much like Melisandre believed in Jon
when she resurrected him, could it be that
Dany will get resurrected by Kinvara?
In my opinion, it's an obvious yes.
If not, they would not mention Drogon flying
toward Volantis which we know is basically
the capital of the Lord of Light religion,
place filled with Red Priests who worship
Dany
and most importantly that’s where Dany’s
biggest supporter among the Red Priests
and also the most powerful of them all, Kinvara
is.
I think this is the same how they ended Jon’s
story as well.
Jon goes back to the Wall and takes the black
even though there’s no need for the Night's
Watch anymore.
Jon knows this and tells Tyrion that it’s
ridiculous the order even exists
because there’s no need for them.
Then in the closing montage, he wears black,
but he also goes beyond the Wall with Tormund,
Ghost and a bunch of wildlings.
Yes, Jon is wearing black, much like Dany
is dead, but it’s implied that he’s not
coming back to the Wall,
but is rather staying beyond, just like how
it’s implied Dany will not stay dead for
long
because the place Drogon is taking her to,
Volantis, pretty much means Dany will get
resurrected.
Jon becomes King beyond the Wall and Dany
the Queen of Essos.
That's an ideal start of season 9.
Dany's storyline would be about her resurrection,
her realization that Essos is where she belongs,
but also her seeking revenge for those who
wronged her.
After being resurrected, Dany with Drogon
and Kinvara by her side would go from Volantis
to Mereen where she left Daario and the Second
Sons in charge.
Dany will decide to rule lands in Essos where
people love her
instead of Westeros where she's feared and
hated.
Same as Jon when Jon was resurrected, Dany
will not want to rule something where people
don’t appreciate her and love her, she will
rule Essos instead, where she is their MHYSSA.
Her ultimate goal is to be the Queen of Essos
based in Mereen
because those are people who deserve her,
but before that she will seek revenge.
As I said, Jon Snow did avenge his own death
upon being resurrected as well.
Dany's list includes Jon who killed her, Tyrion
who made Jon do it
and Sansa who pretty much started all of it
by revealing Jon has the best claims to Tyrion
who then told it to Varys and that's when
the whole plot against her started.
Sansa was Littlefinger's student, she knew
this would cause Dany's downfall and Dany
herself recognized that as well in episode
5 of season 8.
She will go to Westeros with Drogon, Kinvara,
Daario and his 2 000 Second Sons, as well
as remained Unsullied and Dothraki to seek
revenge against those who plotted and executed
her, just like Jon did after he was resurrected.
The Unsullied numbering 4 000 heavy infantry
at the end of season 8 left for Naath,
but I'm certain they will go back to Dany
upon finding out she's alive again.
The Dothraki numbering 50 000 light cavalry,
according to the official report, left Kings
Landing for Essos and will also without a
doubt continue to serve their Khaleesi when
they find out she's not dead after all.
And just like that, Dany again has the greatest
army numbering 56 000 and Drogon,
along with her advisors Kinvara, Grey Worm,
and Daario.
In season 9 I would imagine Dany is driven
by revenge, less naive, and more calculated.
Basically, she will go against half of the
Kingdom; the North ruled by Sansa,
the Westerlands ruled by Tyrion, but also
against Riverlands and the Vale who will support
the North
as they are Stark's relatives.
The Crownlands will also support them as Bran
Stark rules it now and he will help his sister.
The Reach that is now ruled by Bronn would
also support them
since its Tyrion and Bran who gave him those
lands and titles,
but I doubt Bronn will be lord paramount of
the Reach for long.
There is no way all the proud houses of the
Reach would be okay with some random sellsword
with no noble blood or claim to the Reach
be their lord.
Bronn would 100% end up dead in a ditch as
soon as he showed up to claim Highgarden,
then the Hightowers or Redwynes would declare
themselves either lords of Highgarden
or even Kings of the Reach and make it independent.
Dorne and the Iron Islands would then follow
as well.
But even if all these kingdoms don't declare
independency,
that still doesn't change the fact that both
the Iron Islands ruled by Yara Greyjoy
and Dorne ruled by the new Prince of Dorne
would definitely pledge their support Dany
when they find out she's been resurrected.
In the season 8 episode 4, Prince of Dorne
pledged himself to Dany
and I believe he would honor that pledge.
If not, Dany can always win his support by
marrying him,
as we all know that's the best way to make
allies.
Two kingdoms are left to declare their support
to.
King beyond the Wall, Jon Snow is an obvious
one,
Dany is coming to kill him as well, so he
joins forces with Sansa and Bran Stark.
It would also be nice for season 9 to show
why Jon's true parentage was a big thing,
except for being a plot to make Dany paranoid.
Giving it some importance, as well as showing
us what was the reason Jon was brought back
to life because he's not fulfilled his purpose
yet.
Beric Dondarrion did and died in the process.
Melisandre fulfilled her purpose as well,
didn't die in the process, but died when it
was done.
Jon Snow didn't die, he's still alive, meaning
he still has a role to play, a purpose to
fulfill.
That's something I'm looking for in the future
Game of Thrones sequel.
Stormlands and its Lord Gendry is a complicated
one.
Yes, he's a good friend of Starks and Jon
Snow, but they are not the one who legitimized
him,
gave him those lands and titles, it was Dany
and I believe his honor will bound him to
help Dany.
After all, Tyrion did tell Dany that “Lord
of Storms End who will be forever loyal to
you.''
after she legitimized him.
Although Dany is coming to avenge her death,
as I said earlier,
she doesn't plan on ruling Westeros.
That's a good parallel with Roberts Rebellion.
In both cases, the Throne wasn't the main
goal, but at the end when the vengence is
over,
someone has to rule it.
I think that's when Gendry comes in for Dany.
She doesn't want to rule Westeros, she just
wants revenge, but someone will have to rule
it when the war is won and that's when Gendry
comes in.
To secure his loyalty, I believe she will
promise Gendry the throne.
Melisandre did prophesied that Gendry will
make Kings rise and fall.
We didn't see him making kings rise and fall
in season 8, perhaps we will in season 9.
We all know how accurate Melisandre's prophecies
turned out to be in the end.
All of this makes for the bloodiest war in
Westeros.
The argument that Bran Stark, this powerful
three-eyed raven could stop any of this happening
before it actually happens, falls in water,
because if he was that powerful,
then he would stop the Night King before he
actually happened.
Bran couldn't even warg into the Night King's
dragon,
so there will not be any use of him when Daenerys
comes back.
He lives in the past.
In season 9 we could also see many important
events that we were promised to see in Game
of Thrones but didn't.
We could finally see Bran's visions of the
past of Robert's Rebellion,
Robert vs Rhaegar, as well as Rhaegar Targaryen's
reasons to run away with Lyanna Stark
without saying a word to anyone.
What was the reason behind them two not telling
everyone they're in love,
but instead, Rhaegar made it seem like he
kidnapped Lyanna and started a war
that would destroy the Targaryen dynasty.
Perhaps we could also find out more about
the White Walkers and the Night King as well,
something Bran is surely eager to find out
himself.
As he said it himself, Bran Stark lives mostly
in the past now, spending much of his time
in greensight,
so getting to see some of the mysteries unravel
is always a good choice.
Perhaps season 9 would also bring the White
Walkers back into the fold with the Nights
Queen.
We know that the Night King was killed and
destroyed in season 8 along with the White
Walkers he created and the wights he and his
lieutenants created,
but that doesn't mean we've seen the end of
the White Walker story.
Season 9 could introduce us with far more
powerful and complex character than the Night
King,
the Nights Queen.
There are many other parts of the story that
season 9 would include as well,
such as Arya Stark's adventures.
I would expect the return of Jaqen and especially
the return of Quaithe
who I believe Dany will meet after she's resurrected.
All in all, season 8 left a lot of space for
season 9 or some kind of a sequel to Game
of Thrones
with all the clues it left behind and especially
with a confirmation that Drogon is taking
Dany to Volantis where Kinvara is, Dany's
supporter and the most powerful follower of
the Lord of Light,
far more powerful than Melisandre who brought
Jon back.
Why else would Drogon be flying to Volantis?
That’s not where they were born,
that’s not their ancestral home, that’s
not where they lived.
The only connection Dany has with that place
is the Red Priest who supports her
and who has the ability to resurrect people.
All the characters we expected to see in season
8 and play the vital role we could see in
season 9.
Everything left unexplained could be explained,
and most importantly,
we could get a satisfying ending to the series
we all fell in love with.
We definitely will not get season 9 anytime
soon,
but I believe we’ll get some kind of a sequel
to repair the damage done to both Game of
Thrones and HBO.
Perhaps the trilogy, but something will definitely
follow up on where season 8 left.